[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
press conference at midday on Saturday
they did and whether you miss the show
or you just want to recap off the
highlights
stick with us over the next few minutes
and we'll get you sorted we're gonna be
recapping all the big press conferences
so make sure you subscribe so you don't
miss a thing let's start with the big
surprises ea revealed not one but two
new IPs
the first is a story-driven co-op game
from haze light the developers of
brothers are tailored to sun's a bloody
excellent game by the way called a way
out the game looks to be set in the
1970s and follows a pair of criminals as
they progress from prison escape to get
away chase to another caper
interestingly the game is only playable
in split-screen local or online co-op
with each player's experience
independent of the others an example of
which was one player enjoying a cutscene
while the other player was able to move
around the environment a way out is
later to arrive in early 2018 for Xbox
one ps4 and PC oh man I want to play
this one so bad
I loved brothers I loved great stories I
loved new IP and I loved the look of
this game the second you I pay was a
sci-fi futuristic game from Bioware
called anthem we only received a tiny
little teaser video ahead of a proper
reveal at Microsoft's show tomorrow but
what we did see was suits of armor giant
monsters and plenty of foreboding
narration about a wall that keeps people
safe from the evil beyond look it's not
Knight to the Old Republic but I'm still
optimistic as for a game you'll probably
already well acquainted with EA revealed
a sum of battlefield event which will
conclude with the arrival of the Russian
themes multiplayer focused expansion in
the name of the Czar this September the
new expansion will include new weapons
and new behemoth vehicle female soldiers
and new areas not seen in battlefield 1
if that feels like a little too long of
a wait for you a total of 8 new maps
will Daboo over the next few months
including six that are tied to the
expansion battlefield premium members
will get access to the new locations
early the first of which are French
themed nighttime Maps pries d'etat and
naval nights which are both arriving in
July the a also brought it home in the
sports department this year with a
number of interesting announcements a
new trailer for Madden NFL 18 showed off
a story mode called long shot which
follows an aspiring football player
trying to make it into the NFL the mode
also includes a character voice by
moonlight act
Hershel ollie which is pretty damn cool
and yes this all does sound curiously
similar to the story mode in fifa called
the journey which is making a return in
FIFA 18 EA also revealed that the game
will arrive on September 26 in the US
for ps4 Xbox one and PC it'll arrive
worldwide on September 29
if basketball is more your game EA
revealed NBA Live 18 is on the way and
it's going to put emphasis on
personalization
I also hope you're not sick of story
mode because NBA Live 18 will feature a
somewhat RPG s mode called the one where
you play as your own custom character
live 18 also brings back a 5v5 Street
ball mode where you can team up with
friends to take on others on real-life
courts the game is out this September
need for speed payback also finally made
an appearance with a meaty fast and
furious esque gameplay trailer where the
play is shown catching up to a speeding
truck and taking down house in forces by
smashing into them
it features plenty of thrills and fast
cars a previously confirmed that you'll
control three different characters and
it appears you'll switch between them
pretty seamlessly payback is out on
November 10 for ps4 Xbox one and PC Star
Wars Battlefront 2 was also shown off by
way of a new cinematic trailer and a
live 20 V 20 gameplay demo and the most
exciting part all Maps heroes and DLC
will be completely free and they're
promising three times the content of the
first game including More Heroes maps
vehicles and weapons a new feature that
is being introduced is a class system
which will affect things like abilities
and health loadouts
there will also be themed seasons of
content drops from dice the first of
which will revolve around the next main
line star wars film the last Jedi and
introduced Finn and Captain phasma as
playable heroes as was a map on the
planet crate as seen in the film's
teaser
and to prove that they're committed to
showing you all areas of Star Wars an
impressive multiplayer battle on feed at
the capital of Naboo was shown off and
you may remember that from the best
prequel film The Phantom Menace and
guess what you can finally fight as
battle droids that's all the best stuff
we saw at the EA press conference but do
remember that III is just getting kicked
off we're gonna have a roundup for every
single press conference so be sure you
hit that subscribe button
grab our games but now app from iOS
and Android and we'll see you guys
tomorrow afternoon at full Microsoft why
hey Rob here with some more Balfron to
gameplay you're looking at some gorgeous
PC ultra settings footage flying around
as the Naboo Starfighter worth noting
Battlefront - flight controls allow you
to roll left and right making for a far
more enjoyable experience if you want to
see more gameplay like this give us a
like and sub thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the empty teas getting ready to fire
[Music]
no you stop in that empty tea now blast
it shouldn't come to this fallback
positions withdrawal powers we haven't
lost yet
all right we hold back those droids long
enough we can get reinforcements on the
sighting coordinates guard your
positions
hey guys
Nick here with some Need for Speed
payback gameplay captured at e3 this PC
showcase includes eight minutes from
payback single-player campaign and four
more explosive III content be sure to
hit that subscribe button Koenigsegg
Agera zero to 60 in 2.7 seconds and the
house is shiny new toy would be a pity
if something happened to it you read my
mind they're transporting it across city
limits in two hours we intercept then
grab the cargo it'll be part of a convoy
what are you thinking quick hit and run
get me close to the truck and I'll take
care of the rest all right time to show
the house we're back
let's go grab ourselves a hike drones on
mind and I'm looking for the convoy you
guys better hurry to the run deep
all right I remember the house will have
enforced who's protecting the
I'll have to get rid of them first get
me on the truck before it reaches the
Enver Valley tunnel
the aerial surveillance will be blinded
like perfect time for you abra
bulletproof plan
what paint scenario we have fun right
that won't be necessary
how long have you known Jets she always
has a plan
Oh and Plan C and plan D oh and plenty
pull up here
I see trucks almost there and they
brought their money
here we go
give me close to that truck before it
hits the tunnel
[Music]
nice tie one down one to go
that's what I'm talking about let's get
that drunk
[Music]
get me in position
[Applause]
[Music]
got brake checks hard we'll get him
there's something much bigger going on
here they window this bar for dusting
car what's the play
new plan forget the tunnel we get him
before it reaches the city
back up they go back up I see them
[Music]
getting away not for long
[Music]
right walk away we'll handle it
[Music]
[Music]
I think we lost the muscle Mac yep that
drop noodle
[Music]
[Music]
no way you can make it on the back
what's the plan Jess I don't know yet
get me closer
bad idea ladder on the side get up on
his right guys he was so much policing
coming
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's see what she can do
[Music]
don't
[Music]
okay boys let's even the odds
hey Matt you built us all yourself
and artists contend any scrap into a
supercar this crew right here that's the
future
we own these streets Tyler the house
always wins not tonight it didn't
[Applause]
[Music]
Tonie here with some Star Wars
Battlefront 2 gameplay on PC with
everyone's favorite smuggler
han Solo if you like what you see don't
forget to Like and subscribe for more
Star Wars good stuff
[Music]
get their attention
[Music]
running
clean this up and keep moving
[Music]
hey Rob here with some Star Wars
Battlefront 2 gameplay captured on the
PC what's more here's a full match with
some first-person action for more about
front to coverage let us know with a
like and sub thanks for watching
[Music]
glass the transport do it there
[Music]
no you're stopping the deputy now blast
it shouldn't come to this all right we
held back those droids long enough we
can get reinforcements I'm assigning
coordinates guard your positions
[Music]
the seizure be over soon just stay alive
to see it
Hey
get lost the East atrium
keep on checkpoint secure by time
you know where to go
almost there you don't have to beat them
just hold him off myself
[Music]
[Music]
it's too late almost Awards evacuate the
city will take the palace back another
day
Microsoft's biggest gun going into e3
this year is Project Scorpio the final
specs for Microsoft's premium console
were revealed earlier this year but we
still don't know the price and what the
finished product will look like among
other things make sure to click that
subscribe button so when we do find out
more you'll be the first to know
[Music]
a console that can run games natively at
4k and 60 frames per second sounds great
but we'll also need to see if these
games are worth getting excited for
Microsoft has already confirmed that we
won't see Halo 6 this year but there are
still a few other exclusives that should
make an appearance like crackdown 3
which was first announced at e3 2014 and
promises to be a fully destructible
sandbox tied the cloud processing sea of
thieves should also show up this year
it lets you group up with friends in a
shared world and take to the Seas as you
search for treasure and battle other
pirates but if a zombie apocalypse is
more your speed than hopefully we will
see more state of decay to state of
decay was released on the Xbox 360 back
in 2013 and featured perma death and
open-world and resource and survivor
management it was rough around the edges
but it had a lot of great ideas so
expectations for a sequel are
appropriately high finally Microsoft has
a strong India lineup to look forward to
these include the 1930s cartoon style
cuphead the rogue light game below and
Fulbright's next game Tacoma obviously
Microsoft has a few announcements up
their sleeve as well here are some of
our best guesses as to what we might see
I think this year's e3 is going to be
huge for Microsoft and I think in order
for them to really win it win it I think
they need to focus on the game so when
the Xbox one was announced a few years
ago they went real hard and heavy on the
all-in-one entertainment system like
this is how it'll work with Skype you
can watch HBO on it and track things
know like we need to see the game now
especially with Scorpio coming out later
this year
Xbox need to show us that they still
have these incredible first party
studios they need to show us that they
have great deals with dead party devs
and that their games are gonna look
great on the scorpio microsoft just said
that we won't be getting Halo 6 at e3
but they did mention having a little
something to show related to the Halo
franchise we don't know what exactly
that is but halo is such a big exclusive
for Microsoft that it's exactly the shot
in the arm they need to really get
people excited about Xbox again they
have a really good strength in the
scorpio it's gonna be the most powerful
console on the market when it hits if
they can show what it's capable of and a
price tag that's attractive that's gonna
be really good for them but the problem
they have is it lack of games most
notably exclusives so they need to come
out of the
with games that are important to people
but not just for Scorpio owners also for
existing Xbox one owners I still want to
feel like there are Xbox one games
coming out for me if I'm not willing to
immediately jump to another Xbox console
and I think that a lot of people who are
in a similar situation where they don't
want to upfront invest in another
Microsoft console having not got their
money's worth out of the previous one
will want to want more services want
more games want more exclusives so
hopefully Microsoft is thinking broadly
for all of us Microsoft and Xbox fans
instead of just the people who are
potential Xbox Scorpio or project
Scorpio buyers what I think Microsoft
need to do if they want to win this
year's e3 is just play up project
Scorpio 100% the winning formula this
year is the fact that they have the most
powerful console on the market and
that's gonna be a really big deal for
people who want their games running at
the best possible fidelity it's gonna be
a huge thing if Microsoft decided to get
into VR later so I think that's the kind
of thing they need to focus on now I
don't know if this is the thing that
would make Microsoft win a three but I
would love to see a virtual reality
something from Microsoft at e3 now Sony
already has the PlayStation VR
Nintendo's kind of played with augmented
reality on smartphones Microsoft with
Project Scorpio and this more powerful
system could potentially introduce some
kind of virtual reality support and I
think it would be really exciting to be
at e3 and have them announce either
oculus or HTC vive support for projects
for pio and that's what we want to see
let us know if we missed anything in the
comments below and if you want to stay
up to date on the go check out GameSpot
now on iOS or Android it's the fastest
way to see the top ten stories of the
day thanks for watching
[Music]
ei kicked-off III earlier than ever this
year by having their press conference at
midday on Saturday they did and whether
you missed the show or you just want to
recap off the highlights
stick with us over the next few minutes
and we'll get you sorted we're gonna be
recapping all the big press conferences
so make sure you subscribe so you don't
miss a thing let's start with the big
surprises ea revealed not one but two
new IPs
the first is a story-driven co-op game
from haze light the developers of
brothers are tailored to sun's a bloody
excellent game by the way called a way
out the game looks to be set in the
1970s and follows a pair of criminals as
they progress from prison escape to get
away chase to another caper
interestingly the game is only playable
in split-screen local or online co-op
with each player's experience
independent of the others an example of
which was one player enjoying a cutscene
while the other player was able to move
around the environment a way out is
later to arrive in early 2018 for Xbox
one ps4 and PC oh man I want to play
this one so bad
I loved brothers I loved great stories I
loved new IP and I loved the look of
this game the second new IP was a sci-fi
futuristic game from Bioware called
anthem we only received a tiny little
teaser video ahead of a proper reveal at
Microsoft's show tomorrow but what we
did see was suits of armor giant
monsters and plenty of foreboding
narration about a wall that keeps people
safe from the evil beyond look it's not
nice to be able to Republic but I'm
still optimistic as for a game you'll
probably already well acquainted with EA
revealed a sum of battlefield event
which will conclude with the arrival of
the Russian themes multiplayer focused
expansion in the name of the Czar this
September the new expansion will include
new weapons and new behemoth vehicle
female soldiers and new areas not seen
in battlefield 1 if that feels like a
little too long of a wait for you a
total of 8 new maps will do boot a few
months including six that are tied to
the expansion battlefield premium
members will get access to the new
locations early the first of which are
French themed nighttime Maps priests
Tatar and naval Knights which are both
arriving in July they also brought it
home in the sports department this year
with a number of interesting
announcements a new trailer for Madden
NFL 18 showed off a story mode called
launch
which ball is an aspiring football
player trying to make it into the NFL
the mode also includes a character voice
by moonlight actor and her Sheila Ali
which is pretty damn cool and yes this
all does sound curiously similar to the
story mode in FIFA called the journey
which is making a return in FIFA 18 EA
also revealed that the game will arrive
on September 26 in the US for ps4 Xbox
one and PC it'll arrive worldwide on
September 29
if basketball is more your game ea
revealed NBA Live 18 is on the way and
it's going to put emphasis on
personalization I also hope you're not
sick of story modes because NBA Live 18
will feature a somewhat RPG s mode
called the one where you play as your
own custom character live 18 also brings
back a 5v5 Street ball mode where you
can team up with friends to take on
others on real-life courts the game is
out this September need for speed
payback also finally made an appearance
with a meaty fast and furious esque
gameplay trailer whether play is shown
catching up to a speeding truck and
taking down house in forces by smashing
into them it features plenty of thrills
and fast cars a previously confirmed
that you'll control three different
characters and it appears you'll switch
between them pretty seamlessly payback
is out on November 10 for ps4 Xbox one
and PC star wars battlefront 2 was also
shown off by way of a new cinematic
trailer and a live 20 V 20 gameplay demo
and the most exciting part all Maps
heroes and DLC will be completely free
and they're promising three times the
content of the first game including More
Heroes maps vehicles and weapons a new
feature that is being introduced is a
class system which will affect things
like abilities and health loadouts there
will also be themed seasons of content
drops from dice the first of which will
revolve around the next main line star
wars film the last Jedi and introduced
Finn and Captain phasma as playable
heroes as was a map on the planet crate
as seen in the film's teaser and to
prove that they're committed to showing
you all areas of Star Wars an impressive
multiplayer battle on feed at the
capital of Naboo was shown off and you
may remember that from the best prequel
film The Phantom Menace and guess what
you can finally fight as battle droids
that's all the best stuff we saw at the
EA press conference but do remember that
III is just getting kicked off we're
gonna have a roundup but every single
press comfort
so be sure you hit that subscribe button
grab our GameSpot now app from iOS and
Android and we'll see you guys tomorrow
afternoon for Microsoft
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to game
sports coverage of e3 2017 we're kicking
off this Sunday with the Microsoft press
conference pre-show whether you're
joining us on youtube twitch or on our
lovely website gamespot.com welcome
we're here to discuss all the big things
that Microsoft could be bringing to that
press conference joining me this James
is Peter Brown Peter Brown Mike my
hearty guys so we're gonna get our big
first look at Scorpio today finally what
do you think what do you think is gonna
be like the big huge selling point of
the console what do you think Microsoft
have to bring to the press conference to
really get people excited about it
already it's 4k native 4k that's what
distinguishes them from the ps4 Pro
obviously that's kind of taking a
shortcut for K so Microsoft's a big deal
is gonna be hey guys we've got the most
powerful console there is right now and
we've already seen people tweeting
pictures from the meanest teacher yeah
awkward AF I want one real bad I wanna
be able tell everyone I witnessed the
birth of power or whatever it was I
don't think that was it I think the main
draw is gonna be what's gonna be
interesting is to see what they back it
up with in terms of games so far I
haven't heard we haven't heard much
about first party but we've already seen
some references from other publishers to
third party games that could be
appearing there so that's gonna be the
big surprise for me I reckon sure
discuss like I mean there's obviously
gonna be a big first party present but I
don't think there's gonna be much halo
which is very strange because it seems
to be well for the longest time at least
there was Microsoft's flagship yeah
franchise and it just seems like they
may be here as if like a kirsty to say
hey hey let's come in Pete what do you
think is gonna be the big game that to
take center stage that's really tough to
say I mean probably anthem I know Mike
is been amped for that and more I think
about it I think that's probably the
biggest thing they have to show
obviously Assassin's Creed is gonna be
pretty important to the audience as well
but it's the first party stuff that's
not here that has me a little bit
worried but you know I think the kind of
what Tamar was saying you know double
down and this the most powerful hardware
and that's probably all they need to do
to just at least make their message
clear
right now the worry with that is they're
doubling down and saying basically what
they want us they're going to say is
this is the best place to play your
third party great and I don't know if
this in in the mid cycle that's enough
to get people to cough up another four
or five hundred dollars rumored to be to
kind of yeah you know get the best
experience cuz it's not like someone's
gonna come out and say like oh yeah well
I was rubbish now you know somebody's
still gonna be like yeah this is we've
got ps4 Pro so it's I don't know if it's
gonna work for them I think that's the
strategy they will use even with new
stuff like anthem I think a lot of
people might just be like I'm cool I've
got a PC and a ps4 or a ps4 and a switch
right I'm alright so it's gonna be
interesting to see whether third party
alone can be enough to push 4k and a
brand new console mid-cycle digis you
mentioned PC those well because of
Microsoft recently kind of trying to
blur those lines between PC and Xbox and
now they have like play anywhere they
have their cross-platform stuff Mike
what do you think like the scorpio is
gonna add to that do you think it's
gonna sort of divide the two platforms
even more or is it going to be more of a
cohesive relationship between the two i
wrote they were talking about phil
spencer didn't interview with i think he
was like Gamasutra recently and he was
saying that you know like microsoft
itself is rooted or at least it started
with more you know pc focus back in the
day with their hardware at least but now
that you know Scorpio and PlayStation 4
Pro are kind of moving into that mid
cycle hardware upgrade it seems like
even though they're aiming for a console
are the audience they're taking like
hardware cues from the PC space and I'm
interested to see you know they have to
satisfy so many different camps with the
Scorpio or at least they're trying to
write they're trying to get people to
upgrade from an Xbox one or an S -
Scorpio they're trying to I mean
ultimately I would say they're trying to
get people that just have maybe a
PlayStation 4 to go to a Scorpio to have
another console but I don't necessarily
know right now but I'm sold on the
Scorpio yeah I would rather just keep
upgrading my PC for a little less money
when the time comes so yeah like
tomorrow and pizza I think it's up to
the games and right now I don't think
that like Far Cry 5 and Assassin's Creed
origins and these third-party titles
like the idea of playing those on the
Scorpio and being better than anywhere
else is enough to get me excited I want
to see like crackdown 3 be really good
I want to see you know like some sort of
new IP come out I want I don't know like
maybe if anthem looks get enough
although anthem I'm sure I could play my
ps4 and PC as well so I don't know I'm
not completely sold on it yet I don't
know I mean I'm cautious I'm excited to
see what Microsoft have learned because
it seemed it seemed like for the longest
time they were sort of on the back foot
this generation playing catch-up in a
lot of ways to PlayStation let's talk a
little bit about the games that we know
are gonna be here today so obviously
crackdown is gonna have a huge presence
game was first revealed one in 2014 what
do we think we're gonna get today I
think we'll get if they're gonna show
off the I don't know how how invested
they are in cloud computing right now it
seems like it'd be kind of a split thing
yeah I didn't like how much do they want
to talk about it at the same time as
pushing this brand-new Khan right kind
of super-powerful box but yeah all the
really power yeah on a server they'll
really need this box yeah exactly like
you could do this on anything because
it's all in the cloud so I don't know if
how much of they will emphasize that
element of it I think crackdown will
have a good presence and I think it's a
good game to to show off a powerful
console and the power of cloud computing
we saw at Gamescom and before that and
some of the stuff we were seeing in the
early demos of it was pretty incredible
we're seeing massive buildings kind of
like just realistically collide into
each other so I'm excited to see it I
think I'll have a big presence but I
think they'll try and keep it simple
this time whereas they really hopped on
about the cloud computing in previous
years I think they'll just be like hey
it runs on xbox coming out on next day
yeah I think that's it I think
especially because of they're gonna be
emphasizing how the cloud because I
think the cloud stuff only works in
single-player multiplayer as well maybe
not to the same extent I think no I know
because it all it all took place on the
same servers that's why it was
multiplayer only and the single-player
was the stuff that was a process locally
right all right but anyway I mean that's
like if you're gonna be emphasizing how
much the cloud brings to this like what
is why do we have to get it on scope
yeah yeah I mean it's like yeah you can
presume I mean that's kind of like the
benefit of it right and it's kind of
part of their strategy with Scorpio they
want to
present this console that is a step up
from the last Xbox but not kind of
alienate the other audiences and I think
Microsoft is doing a pretty good job of
trying to create this kind of broader
landscape for Xbox Scorpio is gonna
faint that nicely I reckon because you
know the developers are able today
they're being encouraged to create PC
games now and they don't have to point
to much more effort to work on an Xbox
Scorpio whatever it may be called an
xbox one so I think I look for a lot of
people even if it's not specifically
saying oh you need to have this on Xbox
one I think it works in their favor to
have that kind of element of it you can
play this any way you want and I think
they'll really use that as the PR line
to be like yeah but what giving you
options which instead of being like you
have to play this here they'll be like
you place on PC with an Xbox one you can
play it on there to play on that so I
think that's what how they'll spin that
element of it I reckon another game that
we know is gonna have a big presence to
see if thieves
yeah quaint little game it seems like a
very big departure from like the sort of
hardcore heavy audience that they
usually search for yeah so we've seen
another game that's been sort of talked
about for a couple years now right yeah
that's like two years ago
yeah I'm still waiting to see the
element of that game that that really
grabs me you can get drunk and fall off
a boat well I can do that real life's
more the idea of the game seems fun I
remember I played it I think Nick
margarita here at GameSpot played
the Alpha recently where you can
actually find treasure and apparently
you team up with people to like combine
your maps and find you know like x marks
the spot kind of thing in this world but
last year when I played it was just the
team deathmatch where you each take up a
part on the ship to fight the other
ships yeah I know that plays into
actually being a pirate when you come
across people and they might have gold
on their ship you could sink it or at
least like scuttle it and then climb
board get their treasure that all sounds
cool and it seems kind of at odds with
what I always see in this game like
these cartoonish graphics but not that
that's a bad thing but I just still
don't have a good sense of how the
overall structure of the game will work
like the the overworld itself or
traveling from point to point and
deciding when to do these things or how
to do these things like how many people
are gonna be on the sea as well yeah I
wanted to be a really populated game or
would that make
just you know not the right promise I've
coming across that ship in a rare moment
and getting a lot of treasure from it
yeah yeah I'm interested to see it
because I feel like rare as a studio
it's kind of like lost it's a lot of its
identity and you've had other kind of
indie games come up and start eating his
lunch with stuff like ukulele and that
kind of stuff so I mean they given a
heart yeah and I really kind of want to
see a kind of underdog comeback story
from that studio because you know got a
lot of nostalgia and love for it so
there's this quirky elements of this
game but it's not outwardly trying as
hard as it you know like stuff like
banjo and that kind of stuff back in a
day so I want to see more personality in
it and hopefully and we get to see a
little more of that in the demos that
they show off across III know I'm
excited to see more see if these
actually it does look like it has more
of a sense of humor than maybe did the
game so believing like yeah and it's
caught it's got it's kind of like seems
well timed because you know we have
loads of these games where like mike
says what's the structure of it a lot of
game right these days that kind of the
most popular games don't have much of a
structure they just have a framework to
let you have fun the most you know
popular game on PC right yeah it's just
kind of drops you in there unless you
make your own fun and I guess this might
be what that is as well and if they keep
it simple and let it do that it's got a
good chance of you know hitting the kind
of zeitgeist and and doing really well
maybe it's just a problem of how they've
pitched the games so far they haven't
found a really good way to communicate
what it is that makes this click right
they makes all these things I mean I see
stuff like this Dutchman's stuff I don't
know like there's definitely potential
here I just don't I don't know if it's
like maybe it's a marketing problem and
a kind of visibility problem but I don't
know about the fact that I played it for
like four hours total yeah there's
definitely like a lack of clarity to why
it is and what you're supposed to do
yeah well maybe it's one of those games
that like it doesn't click until you
play it like battlegrounds like if you
pitch that to me it's like it's boring
yeah it sounds boring but when you play
it's like intense that'll be along the
same lines we know that um Rod Fergusson
is about in town he's been tweeting that
he's around la are you thinking there's
gonna be a Gears of War husband
I hope so you'll see maybe I hope you
still see if it's eSports I will
literally cry yeah well the big esports
thing last week week before like a
million dollar prize pot you know I mean
the yeah they're deuce for some DLC but
something in me just says he's gonna pop
up and be like we've got new comparative
leagues and everyone's just kind of
collectively yawn and their screen
that's not what we're looking for
hopefully DLC gears for was surprisingly
good like I didn't expect to love it but
I came away not loving it but they kind
of justified coming back so I'd like to
see more of it
I could see them doing like a big push
with the horde mode or something just
because that's where the legs come from
in that game is that hormone is actually
the best incarnation of horde mode I
think since it got introduced and what
gears work - I think gears were three
straight too far from the formula but
yeah gears were four I liked it I
thought it's a really good game and I
thought it was a good first outing for
the coalition because they were kind of
like three four three studios right they
were created specifically to take this
new proper this existing property and
make it their own or at least continue
you know the legacy of the franchise and
I think they did a good job with that
but yet I wonder if they have a tackle
story or if they would tackle you know
like DLC first how would their plans fit
into Scorpio assuming Microsoft wants to
try it try and push everything towards
Scorpio you'd expect them to be one of
the studios that comes out and has
something big for Scorpio so maybe it's
like gears for does it have Scorpio
support like we've had an update for 4k
support so now you can play on your
please play on your $500 machine you
know yeah so it's easy to kind of and it
looks I think it runs on 4k it could be
just a matter of being like okay but
it's not like what's your point it's not
a de facto thing that like every game
that will play on Scorpio will have that
upgrade yeah like those teams have to be
tinkered with a little bit yeah that
could be just that I mean what if they
went back to the backwards compatibility
of the first three games that they
brought and just made all the games
right 4k I mean a little franchise I
mean that would I wouldn't surprise me
they made it push to bring one two three
back when they brought out the whole
election thing what was the remastered
edition of the first game
called ultimate edition ultimate when
they brought that back they're like oh
if you buy this we also for free are
giving you one through three Xbox one
backwards-compatible see them try to
make a push for like we might not have
Gears of War 5 coming anytime soon but
here's like one of this company's
flagship franchises on our new council I
don't know I'm judgement was there -
yeah hey wait I like yours I kind of
like we're not expecting halo 6 no do
you think 343 gonna have any sort of
shirt I mean now welcoming to the stage
it's gonna be like a like a pan over a
mouse chief helmet and in a big stamp
that says 4k I mean the safest bet is
probably Halo Wars 2 DLC but even then
that's better cuz it yeah they did say I
think it's 3 for 3 was saying yeah no
halo 6 for sure we have something for
Halo fans like maybe it's a new Halo
movie it could mean development yeah
like every design the UI for Halo
Waypoint remember Halo Waypoint by the
way yeah I I think it would be awesome
this is just really personal they didn't
have halo reach for the Master Chief
collection and that's one of my favorite
halos because they brought Obst to it
and then everybody's been waiting for
them to bring that to it I'm a huge Halo
fan and I would love to see them say I
don't know we're bringing that to that
but that would have nothing like me yes
please reach me I would have nothing to
do okay let's talk about what else is
gonna be that we're finally gonna get
more from anthem yeah we've got to first
look at it yesterday at EAS press
conference
kind of looks like attack on Titan fall
and I don't know if you've watched the
short-lived sci-fi TV program
almost-human with Karl Urban and it
basically ended on this incredible
cliffhanger that there was this wall
that it was protecting all the humans
from something become a MacGuffin in a
lot of like destiny Game of Thrones what
was the other one someone mentioned
and wolves are everywhere in there
everyone's trying to build a woman yeah
yeah what do you think we gameplay right
you need to have a lengthy yeah so
yesterday during the press conference
they were like there's gonna be plenty
more gameplay at Microsoft so we'll see
a lot of that I'm interested to see what
kind of because there's there's a line
in in the short teaser where it says
like alludes to it being an open world
but also that your decisions matter in
terms of in that bio way away so I'm
trying to figure out how like a Mass
Effect can be overlaid on top of a
destiny and what it becomes it could be
cool to have that open world and kind of
like everyone's contributing and their
decisions are actively changing the wall
around them and that kind of stuff I
mean what we interesting is like did you
when they revealed shadow realms yes I
mean that had the very similar kind of
presence they were like it's gonna have
a single player a bit that you can do
all the Bioware relationship and
decision making stuff but then it's
gonna have this multiplayer component
I'd be interested to see if some of the
ideas from Shadow Realm making made it
into anthem
I wouldn't be surprised they'll be smart
it sounded quite interesting it was fun
I played a bit I remember a games
calling something and it was funny but
like it was with bare bones back then
but the idea was yeah I'm excited to see
hopefully they show us substantial I
think by where he is in the business of
making raising by always profile again
now after Andromeda there's a lot of
yeah they're gonna be like check this
baby's mouth out all the teeth look at
her eyes look at me no cross of life
realizing see some loving those I would
be the only thing that we're talking
about anthem and I was it just reminds
me of like you back in a good shot again
an hour ago when I was a loopy no I'm
I'm just imagining something that
incorporates like the co-op introduced
cuz that you know like presumably if
it's gonna be anything in the destiny
division space they might it will have
some sort of co-op and the only instance
of that we've seen so far as Mass Effect
3 and Andromeda's multiplayer yeah the
more like wave focused defensive kind of
modes I wonder if they would incorporate
any of that kind of combat in
- you know the maybe like strike
missions so to speak in this game if
they had something like that what raids
and whatnot so I'm curious to see how
the gameplay will work cuz I don't think
of fast-paced action when I think of
Bioware at all I know they can do it
like Mass Effect 2 and three kind of
introduced more shooter elements to
their formula but I'm interested to see
how they do it with whatever anthem is
yeah Bioware I love Bioware and for me
Andromeda was a bit of a misstep so I'm
kind of looking forward to seeing what
they are gonna put out there to make
people excited about this you do against
also that yeah the like the veteran
studio this time yeah again we should
also be seeing some state of decay -
hopefully yeah it's no so we were
talking about this on the lobby last
week that we're all a bit burnt out with
zombies yeah but what I'm excited about
for stated okay is that obviously
they're introducing co-op so it's like
the battleground thing going around with
you with your pals but also I'm excited
because they're focusing on the human
element and like the base building and
making sure that you're you and your
friends are safe I'm excited about that
and I just want to see more of it ya
know that that's the thing that I'm
excited about that's why I like the
first state of decay despite its bugs
and this by the fact there was a zombie
game in a very you know a very trite
kind of game tackle at that point and
even now that you know like days gone
it's soni doing but it's trailer I don't
think conveys what I like about state of
decay one but yeah it's the opposite of
shadow of mordor right instead of these
dynamic enemies that you create kind of
and you have these personal beefs with
you have these allies that actually
become important to you right you could
skip this side mission in the early
parts of the first game and then come
back and this house that wasn't supposed
to be overrun with zombies is and then
your favorite allies with you and gets
caught in there it's actually pretty
terrifying kinda like Far Cry twos a lie
system I can't wait to see what they do
with this like you know outside of the
coop which alone sounds awesome I'm
curious because I lost hours to state at
the k1 the first game had a lot of
interesting idea despite me mocking it
but I really I actually liked
in general I mean yeah yeah it's hard to
get over that thematic hurdle these days
because you know you just so many things
come to mind when you see a game like
this it's hard to just really identify
what makes it tick in its own unique way
yeah yeah
but I'm interested to see what they do
how they build on the first game because
it was a surprise like a lot of people
really loved it and so I have high
expectations for the second one and
hopefully it delivers yeah do we think
that so a few years ago Microsoft made a
massive hoo-ha about the indie program I
did xbox what do you thing we're gonna
see hopefully oh my god if cut pear
doesn't come out below always at the
idea to xbox oh oh you know what I
believe there they were affiliated with
ID at Xbox yeah there's been rumors of
some team oh my god if they did a sequel
to Ori I would love it cuz I came really
I just thought it was it was beautiful
game and they played really nicely I had
great levels of complexity and it broke
my heart within the first 10 minutes so
one of my favorite games of all 15 since
the first which is and that game was a
massive success yeah both critically and
I think commercially it did pretty well
as also I want to be surprised if it's
just like a straight-up sequel yeah I
would steal blind forest or in the steal
plan for us what else we think third
party so it's interesting the last few
years the way that Sony and Microsoft
has sort of been stealing exclude their
third party stuff from each other like
Call of Duty has gone Assassin's Creed
in particular seems to be a fair-weather
friend wants to come out on who do you
think we're gonna see this year
my guess is Bethesda yeah I mean after
the whole fallout stuff I think quake is
a good chance a good chap yeah I guess
all agree I think I think
I can think of very many I say here's a
per se I think Bethesda probably the
best bet that's the only one that
immediately comes to minors in these
guys are gonna show up and show
something you know what their publisher
who is like a safe bet yeah almost any
game that they publish these days does
really well
I feel like Microsoft would do well to
just sort of say hey whatever you want
us to work with us on well yeah a lot of
quake champions is they're sort of
they're pushing that this charity 3 they
want to show people that it's gonna be
the big fluid combat and I guess Scorpio
in terms of console is the best way to
show that in 4k okay and also there was
the mobile Bethesda leaks recently
weakened during the leakin weakened but
they had a the Wolfenstein leaked often
found in 4k yeah and then various the
evil within religious showed up on
reddit recently now in 4k if a game came
out in 2014 it's getting sequel this
year yeah I mean I guess like Bethesda
even preempted their own leaks by
putting that thing in their president
yeah yeah I'm not sure well the third
know what Square Enix is up to yes not
like Destiny's gonna they have Sony
going Capcom don't have anything major
that's pretty much it's like the one can
bet on right now I don't know as well
and if you read the unfortunately timed
leak
Game Informer there was a lot of stuff
about sport Scorpio for creeps so I
think maybe Ubisoft might be getting bad
with a newbie you have said that they
have another IP unannounced IP which
could be the Rabbids thing or it could
be something yeah that new IP if it's
not a Nintendo right could you imagine
in tendo allowing no no no it wouldn't
be it wouldn't be that had been if it is
indeed a separate IP it could show up
there in the way that by always thing
was teased like you know here's a bit
now and we'll see your press conference
later on or whatever it may be
yeah it's kind of like a weird way to do
because it's like pulling it's stealing
your own thunder
giving it to Microsoft and then be like
yeah but guys don't forget to come back
to you teasing your own announcements in
someone else's announcements teasing a
teaser yeah fractured Bohol I would say
or shot in the dark
cyberpunk it's come up in the news again
recently yeah you got a feel for the
guys of CD Projekt yes having to say
like a bunch of stuff spin stuff yeah
the black Mouth yeah but it would have
been interesting to see it by yeah
they've said multiple times that they're
still quite far from being able to show
it yeah so I'd be very very surprised I
mean then again Microsoft after the
success of which if anyone's gonna roll
up and be like here's a massive vault of
money give us ten seconds yeah we've
gotten like a little clip a cutscene
period thing yeah maybe another one just
around the themes yeah exactly yeah that
could be a thing that yeah that would be
a surprise but maybe that's where they
put stick of truth I remember Matt and
Trey coming out that year like 2012 yeah
they could come out and show off their
fraction pot holes here yeah I'm
actually really excited for the but
fractured but whole it's more than it
was me or aim before the whole time I I
know you you're like doing Morse code on
my leg I'm actually excited for that
game I didn't play much of the first
when I played it for the first time like
last year and now that I see more of
fractured but whole it's the actual like
the tactical combat I have a serious
conversation I'm being serious I'm I'm
excited for that game alright so guys we
have got like four minutes until the
press conference starts okay hopefully
if they're running to time except please
what is everyone most looking forward to
beat the industrial design of the
Scorpio like a big box with I won eight
I wanted to fill up at least a third of
my living room I'm really curious like
just what this thing's gonna look like
yeah
if Microsoft's gonna go subtle or if
they're gonna go crazy
we had a chat about the little screen on
the front you were saying that you want
and to keep I really want them to keep
that I said yeah I think they should and
they should just have like your download
status on there you can pursue anything
it just plays into that idea of like
this is a very hardcore console yeah
look you have a display for like the
framerate and all that like yeah
everything is it to motivate how's that
yeah but like something like that could
be kind of just neat yeah like a nerdy
perspective I guess yeah I wanna see
anthem I'm really excited to see more of
an yeah I love Bioware kind of down on
them after Andromeda what's up
conversation yeah I'm upset but I you
know it's the a-team they've still
absolutely got it within them to put out
banging games so I'm looking forward to
seeing more of that game and I think
it's gonna be quite different from what
we've seen from Bioware previously a
departure from the old overly RPG nature
of their games they've been slowly
stepping away and moving into action
genres so I'm interested in seeing what
this team has done with that kind of
like progression and how far they've
taken it it could be just something
completely different that we're never
seen from them before and that's
exciting for me Michael were you yeah
I'm really curious about anthem as well
but I'm also just kind of hoping they
show something completely new yeah a
something that's off the radar I am
curious what the halo thing might be I'm
sure it won't be too substantial if I
had if I was a betting person but yeah
I'm curious about anthem just to see
what Bioware does I'm curious kind of
maybe they can finally sell me on see if
these or crackdown 3 yeah I'm interested
to see how much the cloud computing
comes into play in other titles as well
it seems like it's just being that a
push up crackdown a bit yeah but I'm
also excited to see if hololens makes in
appearance I don't know I don't know if
absolute will know but I thought the
when they revealed it with that
minecraft thing a couple years ago it
was so impressive and I just like the
problem but then I don't know if they
want to split their audio that way
they're gonna make this show all of us
it's gonna be confusing yeah I hope it
also there's a little gravestone in the
background I just a scaled down on it
someone's goes west gal Bao yeah is
there gonna be anything from Japan at
this yeah that's mean cuz that was that
was last year war - oh right I mean that
they did have a thing I think they had
you got kinda the castle to Castlevania
like gaming bloodstained yeah that was a
Microsoft booth last year so maybe we'll
see more of that that game is sort of
rolling along cuphead Oh
cuphead yeah and just I need I want to
really stay for that yeah carries about
the price of Scorpio in general we saw a
loose leaks unconference we don't really
know for sure
yeah like the going price in the public
consciousness what 500 now but who knows
if that's actually gonna be it when they
announced it well we have like 30
seconds until we find out so don't
forget to come back right here stay on
this stream actually cuz we're gonna be
here discussing breaking down
Microsoft's press conference talking all
about Scorpio and hopefully the new
reveals that we'll be there come about
butts with Mike we're gonna be talking
about boats brilliant damn right all
right
[Music]
this is the 2017 xbox III briefing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the head of Xbox
Phil Spencer
[Applause]
[Music]
hey dump us
okay good afternoon to those of you with
us here in person watching on this
incredible 4k screen to the millions
watching us around the world or TV
online and to those of you watching and
interacting on mixer on behalf of
everyone on Team Xbox
welcome to e3 2017 when the renegade
group of gamers creators and engineers
came together to form the original Xbox
team and deliver the first Xbox console
we were driven by three principles
empower developers delight gamers and
deliver true hardware and technical
innovation the original Xbox team lived
by the mantra there's no power greater
than X and today we are pre proud to
welcome the newest member of the Xbox
family fittingly named Xbox 1x
Xbox 1x the most powerful console ever
made sets a new quality standard for
gamers and game creators starting on
November 7th Xbox 1x joins the Xbox one
and the Xbox one s when it launches
worldwide now I'd like to introduce one
of our leaders in the Xbox engineering
team responsible for making the Xbox one
experience great for gamers and
developers please welcome my friend
Karine Chowdhury to tell you more
[Applause]
thanks ville it's an honor to be here at
e3 and represent three years of
engineering the team has done to bring
you Xbox 1x from the beginning our focus
on game creators and you the gamer gave
us three big goals we needed to hit
power compatibility and craftsmanship
let's talk power which starts with the
specs six teraflop GPU clocked at one
point one seven two gigahertz twelve
gigabytes of gddr5 memory and 326
gigabytes per second of memory bandwidth
[Applause]
these are impressive numbers that are
more powerful than any other console on
every dimension because that's what it
takes to give game creators the power
they need so you can experience true 4k
resolution 4k textures and 4k assets in
your living room and when we say true 4k
we mean 8 million pixels high dynamic
range wide color gamut premium sound
like dolby atmos and 4k UHD blu-ray
playback
next compatibility we knew compatibility
was critically important for Xbox one X
and your reaction to 360 backward
compatibility has energized the team
even more so right from the start all of
your Xbox one accessories and games will
work with Xbox one X but for the team in
me that wasn't good enough we wanted
more the game library you have today
will look and play even better on Xbox
one X with enhanced visual fidelity
anisotropic filtering and faster load
times even if you haven't made the jump
to a 4k TV yet we designed this product
for you as well since Xbox one X enables
a technique called super sampling the
new 4k games you see on stage today will
look better on your 1080p TV than
anything you've seen before and finally
craftsmanship we meticulously paid
attention to every detail of design as
we crafted our most technically advanced
console ever it starts with the Scorpio
engine we use 16 nanometer technology to
build a 360 square millimeter chip with
seven billion transistors and a 384 bit
wide memory bus this is the fastest most
advanced processor to ever power a
console our premium design means that
every millimetre and every component
within the console has been architected
for maximum power and efficiency our
aspirations were so high an industry
standard approach just wasn't good
enough
the Scorpio engine is so intense that
for the first time ever on a console
we're using a liquid cooled vapor
chamber normally reserved for servers
and high-end PC
[Applause]
an engineer on the Xbox hardware team
invented a new power management system
so innovative we named it after him the
Hovis method uniquely optimizes every
single Xbox one X at the system and
component level to deliver consistent
performance efficiently and elegantly
now it's easy to think all this
technology and capability will mean a
bigger console but again we wanted more
not only have we built the most powerful
console ever Xbox one X is the smallest
Xbox ever
this is the system you asked us to build
and it has been a great honor to design
and build it for you
I couldn't be more proud of our team and
I hope you love it as much as we do now
let's see what this monster can do
exclusive world premiere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please welcome from the ports of racing
franchise Dan Greenawalt
in the automotive world supercars are
debuted at International auto shows
Frankfurt Paris Detroit but through your
passion for racing on Xbox and PC forts
ax has become the premier partner to the
automotive industry
so today for the first time in history a
flagship supercar is making its world
debut here at e3 in front of you
this year we announced a six-year
partnership with Porsche to bring you
amazing experiences both in game and in
person Porsche shares our vision for the
future of racing and eSports and this
car has never been seen outside of the
garden walls abortion now honor but just
lazy dumb may I present 11 gt2 RS
[Music]
[Music]
this is not only the most aggressive
expression of porcius legendary design
it features the most powerful book going
911 engine ever made like the xbox 1x
it's a monster and with over 4.8 million
active players across Xbox and Windows
10 forts ax is one of the largest racing
communities on the planet
you made this historic moment possible
through your passion for racing the
digital and the real worlds are merging
in an unprecedented way so now let's
take a look at the Porsche 911 gt2 RS in
Forza Motorsport 7 running on Xbox one X
I'm joined on stage by two presenters
for our fourth racing championship East
Ward Series I'm Shannon Mackintosh
professional racecar driver and Porsche
driving coach I'll be pushing the gt2 RS
to its limits on the sun-baked streets
of Dubai
and I'm Verena May professional racer
and stud driver I will be fighting to
survive dynamic weather in the
Nurburgring in this Nissan GTR race car
we start with Shannon and her customized
driver on do by using the power of Xbox
one X quarts of motorsport seven runs
and a native 4k and a rock-solid 60
frames per second and we have the
additional power to deliver shocking low
levels of detail using super high res
lap resolution assets we've recreated
the intense feel of one of the greatest
driving roads in the world
the habib mountain pass
but in Fortune motorsport seven we've
reimagined the entire racing experience
on all devices racing is more immersive
and dynamic ominous skies roll in as car
parts rattle and vibrates
we've made racing more epic and grand
race through living environments
featuring spectacular vistas and massive
scale you can see we've made racing more
dynamic and surprising dynamic bubbles
grow as a storm unleashes its fury
it's more thrilling and competitive feel
the intense heat grease up your tires as
you battle your rivals and it's more
beautiful and alive dark skies open up
and change as the Sun emerges from the
clouds for a breathtaking finish
[Music]
Racing is reborn in Forza whether
running on the Xbox one family of
consoles or Windows 10 pcs Fortson
motorsport 7 is the most technically
advanced and comprehensive racing games
ever made with more than 700 cars it
features the largest collection of
Lamborghinis Ferraris and Porsches ever
assembled today you were the first
people to see the 2018 Porsche 911 gt2
RS and this week at e3 like me you can
be the first to drive it so come
experience the most powerful road-going
911 ever made on the Xbox one X the most
powerful console ever made in Forza
Motorsport 7 thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
I'm gonna play a ton of Forza Motorsport
seven when a chips on October 3rd and
when Xbox 1x launches we will all get to
experience forts of motorsports 7 in
true 4k at 60 frames per second today
we're gonna showcase the world's
greatest creators with a lineup of
different types of games for every type
of gamer it is the largest and I believe
the most diverse lineup of games that
we've ever shown on our Xbox e3 stage
games from creators large and small
games that inspire and challenge us
games that transport us to new worlds
and offer us new perspectives and games
that push the boundary of our art form
today we will feature 42 games here on
our stage including 22 games with
console exclusivity on Xbox Live
every one of these games will play great
on each member of the Xbox one family
but of course they will play best on
Xbox one X up next is a game from a
creative team that built their franchise
on Xbox in 2010 for a games worked with
us to launch a single-player masterpiece
that I played on xbox 360 now I'm
honored to bring them back with the
premiere of their next work running in
engine in true 4k
world premiere
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
world premiere we are the first the
[Music]
first to see the gods
the first to tame their beasts
the first to guard the soul from evil
[Music]
we conquered this land and built an
empire
but there are whispers on the wind a
Brotherhood born in the shadows
they are the first to call themselves
the assassins
[Applause]
[Music]
he's welcome from the song creative
director Zhang and all
[Music]
thank you ancient Egypt is the
birthplace of modern civilization and it
is also the birthplace of the assassins
Brotherhood Assassin's Creed origins is
taking you to the perfect setting for an
epic gaming adventure Egypt 3,000 years
of use and some sweet origins is also
the story of one man last time the
protector of his community
an Egyptian sheriff if you like and he
struggle against the dark forces that
corrupt ancient Egypt we live the
foundation design Brotherhood which
reads in ancient Egypt great so far time
to think and spend our gameplay
mechanics we added many RPG elements to
a huge systemic world more detailed
analyze than ever before so today we are
very proud to show you what the game
looks like on X born white xbox one x
running in 4k and now just for you
Barack is coming back to see WA his home
town to kill the fake Oracle Medina
world premiere
[Music]
[Music]
see wha my home the secret oasis
be my eyes
this temple resembles a fortress what
has happened
[Music]
there you are
metonym on the next masked one on my
list
now it is my turn to tip the balance of
Anubis
better be careful here
a fine bow
is too dangerous pass for now
guide me send me tuna muna
[Music]
you will die
the Doudna moon
at Xbox we've always believed in the
power of games to unite us all today
communities of gamers not only play
together they create together and watch
together a whole new genre of games has
emerged design for both the player and
the community and with mixer we're
innovating new features to make these
experiences even better this one's
special of all the games in this genre
here is one that the world is having as
much fun watching as they are playing
and I can tell you that includes many of
us a team Xbox the creative director of
player unknowns battlegrounds is a gamer
turned developer who designed this game
together with a passionate community
please welcome player unknown himself
Brendon Greene
[Applause]
thanks Ville good afternoon everyone
player unknowns battlegrounds is a
multiplayer battle royale where you must
fight against a hundred other players to
be the last one standing our team's
focus is to bring the most complete
battle royale experience ever to console
and deliver a great experience across
all Xbox one devices our development is
truly community driven and we are much
of our success to everyone who's given
us feedback over the past year with over
3 million PC players to date we can't
wait to bring player unknowns
battlegrounds exclusively to Xbox one
later this year with an update for Xbox
1x enhancements shipping with the final
version see you on the battleground
everyone exclusive
[Applause]
[Applause]
exclusive
[Music]
[Applause]
exclusive
what would you do
if the world you move
was long
all the comforts the simple Blake took
for granted
how would you protect yourself and the
ones you love when their protectors
cannae themselves
[Music]
now will you decide who belongs
how will you choose a placed column how
we build it
[Music]
walk together to defend it
from the terror
just outside of the house
[Music]
and you get hungry cold what risks will
you take what mistakes will you make and
the only family you've got is about to
tear itself apart will you end the life
wait or save it this is our only one we
need everybody we've got
get into deep realize no one gets a
second how will you find the strength to
carry on
in this world of the living and the dead
how will you live
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
exclusive
two players remaining
[Music]
she's gotta take the win let's move on
to the next arena here we're following
bloody marrow there's only two players
left in this particular map those tracks
are leading up but that treat is gonna
give them direct information that red
outline is immortal unicorn and he's
letting it about a hundred meters away
now looks like you might be crafting or
something but what is this that bloody
marrow is gonna do getting ever you're
going to feel it to cloak it up if you
walk in through the front door or what
looks like it's gonna sneak in the back
window here we go
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please welcome from ou yang brand
director Lydia winters
[Applause]
this summer
millions of Minecraft players will be
able to play together on the device of
their choice for the first time xbox
live will unite the global minecraft
community across mobile VR Windows 10
pcs and consoles as part of this effort
we're excited to welcome player made
skins Maps textures and massive
community run servers into the game
itself because we know that the amazing
content you create makes minecraft even
better this fall minecraft will receive
a free 4k update that brings more
graphical options to the game but we
didn't stop there with all this talk
about graphics we're taking things one
step further today
we're revealing a new look from
minecraft that we're super duper excited
for you to try out one that's inspired
by the power of Xbox one X and available
this fall let's check it out
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
minecraft in 4k when the Minecraft team
showed me the first version of the game
in 4k I was blown away mo yang is a
great example of a studio that started
something new and different that led to
a global phenomenon at Xbox we're
searching for games that are fresh new
and in some cases familiar that means
ensuring that the biggest third-party
franchises you want to play are there
for you on Xbox one of course you'll
find these great games in the Xbox Store
available for pre-order today but
bringing the biggest blockbuster
franchise is just one part of the job
delivering broad diverse and new games
to Xbox means searching to find unique
games from creators around the world
that will surprise and delight to me
these next few games do just that
starting with the game I got to play on
a recent trip to Japan it's hilarious a
little crazy and a whole lot of fun
let's take a look at it world premiere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
exclusive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
exclusive
[Music]
[Music]
exclusive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we've scoured the globe meeting with
creative artists and development teams
and I'm often surprised and humbled by
their work whether it's a story that can
only be born of a different land or
artistic design and storytelling that in
a single moment can capture your
imagination and inspire there is much to
be learned by looking beyond borders our
first party is also a place of
innovation and creativity today I'm
excited to share with you an extended
look at never-before-seen gameplay from
rare shared world adventure sea of
thieves exclusive
the joy of a new voyage far across the
sea of thieves just you the wide open
world at Obama's not just you she's here
too oh and this guy's here but but the
point is this is a shared world right
for exploring and reading with your fine
pirate crew welcome scurrying around
making themselves useful that's what we
like to see the world of sea of beans
speeds with possibilities and all you
have to do is jump in and up she goes
[Music]
few things tend to pirate like the siren
song of a lootable shipwreck careful
though there can be anything down there
literally there could be anything we
haven't finished designing it yet joking
that was a joke ah sunken treasure it's
like a pirate performance points
every players decisions and discoveries
will be different but however you plan
on seeking your fortune it pays to be
prepared for gigantic lumps of iron
these are surprisingly portable amazing
workmanship enemy bear get them back on
board while the coast is clear there's
really no sense in pushing your luck
down here that is not a beast you want
to pick a fight with yes it's possible
to take on these two thete errors of the
deep you're not much used to your crew
bending too
sometimes a tactical key is perfectly
acceptable in the spirit of that
legendary pirate captain pathetic Dee
[Music]
thankfully for every tense standoff
there's a moment of celebration or
shared wonder but for now store your
hard-earned loot and enjoy the voyage on
Devil's Reds beneath the sands the gold
lies hidden from thieving hands here we
are at Devil's Ridge nice transition by
the way
and sold you ship from the heart of the
sea to the islands shore where you'll
explore jungles and coves clef tops and
caverns every region has it's very own
landmarks and over time you'll uncover
hidden shortcuts abandoned stashes and
Vestas they'll steal your grog soaked
breath away and yes sometimes you'll
encounter people who for whatever reason
we'd like to blow you into little pieces
that's pirating for you keep that pestle
cranked because you'll also face that
roaming remains of those Raiders who
came before you caught shortly pursuit
of their own legends
and afterlife of waiting and trouble me
Pluto all your bets follow it's what he
would have wanted now make sure your
crew me it's all about part to play yep
that works and look the riddle map seek
the cursed boss train where there is no
sky it lies and wheat for a link held
high right well that's gotta be around
here somewhere
but if you've got bad feeling you can
always leave someone on board to brace
the ship for a speedy galley this
decision ah looks like they've snuffed
out that place where there's no sky Fame
to pool your resources as you plunge
into the unknown it would be easy to
come a cropper in these claustrophobic
caves you don't want to wander off track
unless of course you're streaming and
you'll have loads of people in the chat
telling you what to do anyway
the pineapple is probably nothing just
kids
of course the premier plunder isn't just
lying around to be clean by any old
drunken bum block you need to watch out
for likely locations following your map
clues and your instincts to make a light
work of each new mister
late one well Blanton took their you're
welcome
anyway step 11 paces Northwest through
the gloom beg my chest from its tomb and
with that we're one step closer to
payday
then again some of the loot in these
parts has lain undisturbed for a long
long time that has to be the spot you
can practically taste the treasure good
call on the double duty shovel work to
that store mate says was nipping at your
heels very nice
of course the trouble with treasure as a
rule is that the owners really like to
hang on to crew to watch your back and
while they're doing that it's playing
for another strategic withdrawal with
the loot
nope no Matt wait that's it
he's in there
don't stop keep going almost there watch
that easy
[Music]
[Music]
if you can regularly beat the odds and
get chest back to your ship you'll be
able to turn a tidy profit by trading
the men and opals that's just the tiny
matter of making it through this storm
in one piece
[Music]
[Music]
all pirate life is here on the sea of
thieves and you can let viewers however
you want to rally your crew
st. seal for riches and infamy become a
pirate of legend
just try not to be this one
[Applause]
exclusive
[Music]
[Applause]
exclusive world premiere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
exclusive
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
exclusive they killed the power around
the world we're gonna light it back up
because this is far from over in fact
it's only just gone that's why we know
it's time to get to work
[Music]
some people never have trouble
they don't know what the struggle is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
at Xbox it's not just about finding
creative artists it's about empowering
them and nurturing them helping shine a
light on their work making it easy for
them to build and share their creations
that's why the idea Xbox program is so
important to us the team has released
over 500 games on Xbox one and Windows
10 through the ID at Xbox program and
this is not just a milestone for the
program and the independent developer
community it's a milestone for everyone
who loves great games I hope you're
reminded today why it's so great to be a
gamer on Xbox action adventure story
skill surprise these next few games
bring it all together let's start with
the game whose stylistic approach alone
makes it something very special
exclusive
the dark is older than the light
at last a day dawned and we rose with
this first light but that light was a
betrayal only fleeting
in its wake the night returns blame us
after lifetimes the light grows again
they didn't bomb
[Music]
rather than just survive in the dark
this rebirth will end our wandering
[Music]
world premiere
[Music]
you
[Music]
somebody turn and ear
I feel now I feel known in this kingdom
I feel numb I feel numb in this king
[Music]
[Music]
Rachel
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please welcome from monolith productions
vice president of creative michael de
platter
you prod to you mili ate me you left
your mark on me buddy thing work you
burn my mind dry I'll kill you until
this moment you have not known suffering
alright enough of your mouth burrs so
now I'm gonna kill you for all these
orcs to say oh I said you were an
optimist know what that is mine
it's about sizing up a situation that's
bloody impossible and saying yeah
alright I'll have a go I'm exactly the
same like him in shadow immortal
we introduced a way to create unique
personal stories for every player and in
shadow of war we're expanding the
Nemesis system to new features were
really excited about are forging an army
of followers and nemesis fortresses here
we'll use the ring of power and recruit
this Olaf Brewster chopper to expand our
army then we're going to assault a
fortress controlled by one of our odds
over lovers
great to yield I'd ask you um a that
little Schwartz good for a tickle maybe
but you're gonna need more than that
chance I'd made out nice blonde Ranger
this never happened to beetle
bronto load same thing really
it results me ripping spines out which I
like to do anyway so either ways to win
a fine addition to our man nice burst
from your owner I will be your shadow no
one gets to you without my say-so
don't worry about my enemies they will
all follow eventually you want to plant
your flag in Mordor you'll need to do a
deep there's a fortress near boy
I said ruled by a two-headed frog bigger
Sun man hmm
deadly smart which Marcus he'd have to
be given the two aides you take him
there and he'll send a message to sour
on and get yourself some nice new digs
as part of the bargain they're not going
to do this alone gather your troops will
do up just make sure you let me pop his
heads off words yeah
[Music]
so we already have a few loyal followers
in our army and recruiting brute means
we're ready to assault the fortress and
overthrow the overlord we're enormous ly
expanding the open world of Mordor to
new regions like Sarah Gaston Tirith
angle morose a massive living breathing
world filled with orc society tribes and
wildlife as well as stories and secrets
have died but I survived more than that
I thrived my brothers put me back
together stronger than ever but they
didn't make me into what I am you geege
you created the machine
machine these transit across Mordor
seeking vengeance he's one of the seven
year old crimes without any
you dishonor the stealing
instead of killing the machine will
dominate his manner we can take
advantage of his abilities during the
florges assaults you to do before we
charge headfirst into battle we should
plan our attack and select our followers
[Applause]
my black speech is a little rusty x9r
sing good she's a pain in the ass back
to has it a case he sayd gonna die
horribly bad mark on a black well I will
handle the Overlord you focus on the
defenders define focus
[Applause]
there are unlimited ways to forge your
story in conquer Mordor in shadow of war
and we can't wait to show you more this
week at e3 thank you very much
exclusive world premiere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Auri affirms my belief in the beauty
artistry and heart within the art of
gaming we believe that games like books
movies and music should be celebrated
and enjoyed by countless generations
we're passionate about preserving and
celebrating the games you own the
classics of the past and the genres you
love to play that's why two years ago we
launched the xbox backward compatibility
program to bring Xbox 360 games to your
Xbox one and we've seen tremendous
growth in the program today our library
of games stands at 385 titles and over
half of Xbox one gamers have played a
backward compatible game but I've heard
your feedback and you want more today
I'm pleased to announce an exciting
expansion to the program
our team of engineers are working hard
to bring us some of your favorite
original Xbox game to today's Xbox one
library including a fan favorite that
I'm asked about often by the community
crimson skies and it looks great and
like the Xbox 360 games og games Lua
look better and play better across the
Xbox one family we'll have more to share
about this program when it launches
later this year I'm proud of the library
of games available today on Xbox one
all of them will benefit from the
performance and power when you play them
on Xbox one X but we won't stop there
I'm excited announce that if you own
Gears of War four forts of horizon three
Killer Instinct Halo Wars 2 or minecraft
will providing 4k updates to these
titles for free
and we already have over 30 titles from
our third-party partners that are
planning to provide free updates as part
of our Xbox 1x enhanced program titles
like Final Fantasy 15 Resident Evil 7
Tom Clancy's Ghost Recon wildlands and
rocket League just to name a few
this means you probably already have a
large library of titles that you own
today that will automatically get better
on Xbox 1x today we showcase some of the
world's greatest creators with a lineup
of different types of games for every
type of gamer we showed you the largest
and most diverse lineup of new games
that have ever appeared on our stage
from every corner of the globe
from developers large and small 42 games
including 22 with console exclusivity on
Xbox one and you're also going to be
able to play all of the biggest
cross-platform blockbusters on Xbox one
and every game will play great across
the Xbox one family and on Xbox one X
runs every single game you've seen even
better so if you haven't joined the Xbox
one family now's the time this week
you'll find Xbox 1s available in the US
for $249 and on November 7th will begin
worldwide rollout of Xbox one X the
world's most powerful console at $4.99
be the first to experience unrivaled
power and performance on the Xbox one we
close today's show by looking to the
future with a really great partner
they've been with us from the earliest
days of Project Scorpio and they're
building
an incredible game that takes advantage
of the power and performance of the Xbox
one family and the new Xbox 1x please
welcome Patrick Sutherland executive
vice president EA worldwide studios
[Applause]
new IP is the lifeblood of our industry
it's also risky at ei we have teams
dreaming up a lot of projects and only
the greatest will make it their way to
you and that's okay it's all a part of
the creative process and it's worth it
because when you find something special
there is no better feeling as a
developer than introducing players to a
brand new world and as a player there's
no better feeling than losing yourself
in a completely new experience our
developers of Bioware have been creating
something truly special a huge open
world that is lush savage mysterious and
ever-changing filled with interesting
characters and new types of gameplay
you'll enjoy with your friends for years
to come
this is what's possible we take an
extraordinary vision and combine it with
the latest technologies and hardware
amazing concepts become possible great
ideas become reality so here we are and
we are so excited to share this with all
of you on behalf of the team and pyroar
let's see what this game looks like
running on an Xbox one X here's John
Warner from Bioware to show you Anthem
[Applause]
hi I'm John Warner games record for
anthem here is the world premiere of
anthems gameplay
[Music]
freelancer Braxley
listen there's trouble big trouble
what did you do mistake I hired some
people they weren't freelancers I know
they said they could handle it and the
price was right
I thought maybe unbelievable you're
right it was stupid I'm sorry but
they're still out there somewhere if you
could just bring them back anything you
need
in the world of anthem you and your
friends are freelancers the heroes who
leave the safety of the walls of poor
Tarsus to explore the unknown and
protect humanity
let's join two players as they head out
on an expedition just grabbing some
supplies just already what are you gonna
use today I always go with the Colossus
I'm gonna use my ranger try out some new
upgrades
[Music]
every player will own an array of
exosuits we call javelins these suits
give players superhuman capabilities and
are heavily customizable so they look
and play how you want
this is a vast open world you explore
with your friends
each javelin exosuit has its own unique
play style the Ranger is balanced in all
purpose while the Colossus is a tanking
powerhouse
the world of anthem is hostile and
threats can come from any direction
dynamic world was unexpected is around
every corner
Oh
have you been in there yet have it oh
you should do that later with Kip you
can use the XP hello it's Roger
I think we got some action
under attack anyone in the area or other
attack
you can equip your javelin exosuit with
gear that brings devastating power to
combat
all the scars have a heavy have time to
use that mortar
[Music]
large-scale world events like shaper
storms are dynamic and pull you off the
beaten path with the promise of new
stories to discover shapers dharman
coming okay
actually let's get some more people hold
on a sec hey guys what's up
right behind you
the storms getting crazy
[Music]
what are we supposed to do fly into it
all right
see on the other side
our story is out there
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back we've just seen the world
marvel of Scorpio very exciting I mean
Microsoft did like what 42 games just
now there's a lot of games I was
expecting I guess let's start from the
top we are here with the hottest and
freshest of takes I'm Lucy James joined
by Peter Brown Mike Mahadi
and tomorrow saying that peace peace and
love guys were very excited Scorpio
looks like Geoff Keighley was correct
with the fauna and I'm price point is it
what does everyone think I mean I think
it makes sense for a lot of reasons the
console looks really slick a lot of the
stuff we saw looks like it's running on
it you know in a very impressive way
yeah at 4k
yeah I mean how many times what do you
think about how the console looks goes I
think it looks good like it's kind of
understated almost I like the sleek
black no it look like it has something
only on the front if anything that was
maybe like an infrared I think the big
question is they said it's the smallest
Xbox ever made that's great not hot
though well the question is is the power
supply etc internal yeah the Xbox one is
currently is pretty great because even
have that big brick huge annoyance and
obviously Microsoft well know that have
done their research and putting their
due diligence when it comes to cooling
but they do have a history we're
screwing up cooling off so it's still
just a in the back of my head like is
that gonna be properly cooled are we
gonna have a red ring situation many
many years I'm sure it's gonna be fine
but like that that is an impressively
small device for its packing yeah I'm
looking forward to this actually 500
makes sense
um it's I still think they might have a
little bit of a problem explaining why
their 4k is $100 worth $100 more than
Sony's now if I'm not mistaken right
because I know you know I think
obviously Sony but the ps4 pro uses like
a workaround to have 4k right it's not
like true native 4k no it's upscale yeah
yeah so I mean
that like we know that but I think the
people who just want to know which
console to get or know if they're gonna
be able to explain that to them but yeah
I don't know I'm okay with 500 but I
they did show a few like exclusives and
I think they're unclear throughout the
show whether they're gonna be timed
exclusives whether they're exclusives in
general let's start at the top so Dan
Greenawalt came out and showed off brand
new Ford sir did you know they had a
partnership with Porsche listen guys
just for future reference don't show off
cause your press conference right at one
point he said Porsche is invested in the
future of eSports no they're not I'm
sure they're ours just because you don't
like Porsches just mean there weren't
people I thought it was a cool-looking
car no I would drive one and I mean it
is like probably the best game they had
to showcase how great it looked I think
I looked it look I mean anthem blew me
away in terms of visual yeah yeah that's
the one I mean like a seven-point like
we just expect for that to look good
yeah and it always looks good and it's
reached a point where I can't tell how
good it looks because it always looks
good okay cool it looks like a very good
looking for the game
camel b-roll is confusing to me but yeah
especially when I start raining in the
slick roads those look good as they
usually do it feels really good
nice little close-up shots if that I
guess but then I mean first big actual
reveal was a new metro game Metro Exodus
that was my favorite thing for the show
I think yeah I mean they didn't really
show much and it was weird
I was recently playing the Redux of 2033
and last light last light is one of my
favorite games I think it's hugely
underrated in terms of pacing I think
it's kind of almost like a half-life 2
level more people should play it I think
but I'm really glad Microsoft devoted so
much time to this because you know
they're kind of cult classics almost
they did well obviously when they
released them as the Redux but I
was curious how much this was actual
seemed like a lot of the animations were
more exaggerated for the presentation
and I think they would be in-game yeah
but this looked really good I think this
is a seriously I feel like he's poised
on like massive it's got a lot of
parallels with The Witcher where the
first two games were like good games we
read of niche and then that third game
it just absolutely blew up yeah fact
that they're going open-world and it's I
think I feel like it has the potential
to blow up in a similar way though yeah
it's definitely got like the world
behind it and kind of like you played
The Witcher 3 and a lot of people came
to and they're like man I need to go
back and explore the rest of this
universe yeah and there is a whole load
of that depth for metro and all the kind
of source material around it so yeah it
could be really really cool
yeah they just say to see how the
survival aspects come into play because
in the first two games when you go above
the surface you had to like make sure
you had enough replacement gas mask
canisters you had to make sure you had
they can your letter and whatnot that'd
be interesting to see how they take an
open world and implement those you
wonder if they're gonna take down those
survival mechanics at all or what I
think they must be have to redo it in a
different way because when we don't know
if this is Artyom yeah yeah I imagine
because look at the lady who's on the
train at the end she shouts human
sounded like that yeah but like as he
goes outside he can take his mask off so
that really suggested like quite a lot
of time my first yeah I feel like it
might be a it might be call if it if it
has like weather effects we're kind of
like dust clouds yeah and then you have
to kind of on-the-fly figure out if
you've got your equipped to survive it
yeah but yeah it looks cool it looks
ambitious as well yeah I like that he
pulls up an actual like I don't even
know if it's the right turn but like
diegetic map it's not part of your UI
pulls it up yes I got it
I people I think we had heard like kind
of rumors about this before the show and
people were saying like it sounds like
it could be maybe like more hardcore
survival fallout for almost I'm sure not
to that scale and not the same kind of
sandbox exploration that the Bethesda
games are known for but it does seem to
me obviously the post-apocalyptic is the
clear parallel but I'm really excited to
go back into this world just a really
interesting what based off Dimitri
Bukovsky yeah
yeah but all these weapons seems like
it's got the same flavor as the first
two games like pneumatic weapons like
just you know and scramble together from
spare parts and everything and I love
that it's this overgrown look now it's
almost like Gears of War kind of look to
it looks like they're really playing up
the idea of when means to be a ranger
yeah in the world like and that means
kind of emphasizing the survivalist
nature of it and kind of thinking on the
fly while you're out there and being
kind of the guy above-ground in danger
exploring and mapping out for the people
who are in hiding and then kind of
disseminating that information and
exploring the wall around you yes it
looks real cool I like the idea of that
yeah definitely
I think this is my maybe not biggest
surprise of the show but it this is the
one I came away like I couldn't stop
thinking about this yeah yeah I'm
probably coming up to my favorite sort
of first look that we saw myself press
conference would be Assassin's Creed
origins so oh my god looks good as a
child I wanted to be an Egyptologist
yeah and I really loved the way that
they've taken a year off and they sort
of it looks like they've addressed all
the things that people kept bitching
about its essence greed hmm I saw a lot
of hot fresh takes on Twitter that they
had the thief stone and the jump and
slow and bow time thing from Zelda
horizon but I mean it just looks cool as
hell because mind arrow too which I
missed
yeah telepathically propelled that arrow
but yeah the one thing I noticed that
stood out we just had a few people here
at GameSpot go to play this a little bit
earlier we'll have them we'll be able to
talk more about that later but the
combat like it when they actually not
the assassination that was all seem you
know the trite ones that have really
like pervaded the Assassin's Creed
series but we actually started like
fighting with the bigger enemies there's
actually more of uh I get Dark Souls
which are kind of action RPG style I
mean obviously because we are watching
it not currently playing it but like
from the sound effect and the way that
the characters are moving it felt like
that combat had way more impact because
in Assassin's it felt like you could
like just cut through thin air but you'd
be cutting through an enemy whereas this
it felt like I'm so hesitant
call it Dark Souls II yeah but you know
it did definitely give off that vibe
getting rid of the mini-map as well like
it seems like a thing that wouldn't be
much a very big change but honestly it
just looks so much cleaner and more open
and it feels like there's more
possibilities than just being having to
keep your eye in the bottom I feel like
there you can see elements of other
Vsauce games in here which is classic
Ubisoft but like combat it felt kind of
it had the weight off for honor yeah
yeah kind of like the swinging and the
kind of startup and animations that kind
of thing yes it does look like the
combat feels a little wait year this
time around so I'm excited to see how
that although it does have got rid of a
mini-map and stuff so they're trying to
clean it up a bit
it's still very gamey at times like for
example that bit way it tells you to
level up and then it all turns to dust
and goes into the corner and becomes
this like little there goes into like
little vial and and right inside really
kind of caught my eye and maybe a bit
jarring we've heard the rest of it
because it was so clean up until that
point but still it's a hell of a lot
cleaner than the last few Assassin's
Creed games where it was just icon see
everywhere yeah but yeah it's exciting I
like the crouching which kind of not is
maybe perhaps an not too like a little
more improved stealth because that's
something I feel like has been lacking
in recent years in the series so that
looks that's exciting to me as someone
who likes to play stealth games
just a little more mechanical agency in
general whereas so much of the earlier
games was contextual when you and I were
watching this week and you were kind of
wondering if the combat was still gonna
be that contextual attack or counter
attack binary kind of thing but it
doesn't look like that's the case I'm
gonna tip oh I thought that was Imhotep
when I read it I was like and then they
said like oh he was a last member of the
Magi I was like oh my god it's basically
the mummy the recent one the really good
one anyway playing unknown battlegrounds
is big get yeah and that is a huge news
I do wonder though how long that will
last like it's it's doing well now
we've seen these kind of games come and
go I remember when no one was everyone
was just talking about h1z1 and now look
at it it's like mmm it's hot for a
little while and I guess it's fair play
to Microsoft for striking while the
iron's hot get in on the action and
while people are interested in it and it
looks like they've introduced some cool
new mechanics to it well like I don't
remember being able to shoot so that's
it's definitely gonna be interesting to
see how that community weather one
builds on on a console I think it will
but how long it sticks around for who
knows
do you think was very interesting that
they showed that and then they had
another game in the middle like deep
broke galactic and then they wouldn't
straight to state of decay - yeah there
was like a bit too much of an overlap
especially if you like bringing these
zero exclusives whatever that currently
means for Microsoft but I felt like they
were shown a bit too close together
ya know speaking of state of decay -
while the B rolls up it was the first
game despite how much I loved it and I
sometimes would just go back to play it
just to see how like the Allies I made
were doing it looked kind of janky even
in this president yeah like the girl
that they saved she did the same like
machete animation over and over and it
wasn't actually connecting with his
ahhmm be and then just in general the
movement what kind of broken and I don't
know it was almost I almost didn't mind
in the first game as much because they
did so many novel things with the game
but I don't know I'm kind of worried
about how this looked I kind of felt
like they'd accidentally mixed up the
b-roll for unknown for battlegrounds
what's Dave decay should look like at
this yeah it's still got a little time
in development is clearly yet if they
mentioned state of decay what is this
before the end of the year yeah I think
it just might but yeah it's it's got
time to kind of sort that stuff out
personally I think I think it looks fine
but again it doesn't have it's a similar
issue I have with days gone the Sony
game it's like it still feels like a
very much we're trying to do Walking
Dead yeah I'm cool I'm cool about that
thanks yeah try to do wacky does kind of
a low bar - yeah yeah
I yeah I don't know maybe kind of like
in the same vein of Assassin's Creed
maybe the break from zombie games if
there was one I think there was like a
few years that we had since we've had
like a slew of zombie games maybe I'll
be ready for this but yeah right here it
kind of looks you know very polished yet
no and they do have time like the more
said but yeah no and again I could
easily forgive those faults if like the
same you know the reverse like Nemesis
system you know it looks like that's
obviously still the focus and building a
base and going out on the quest that you
decide to go out on with the allies you
choose and kind of connect to I'll be
fine but it's still kind of
disconcerting to see it at an e3
presentation yeah alright moving on we
had the Darwin project shoutcaster out
of nowhere and then someone from Mixit
chimed in happened so hard but then
minecraft so Minecraft big announcement
cross-platform play mmm definitely sort
of avoiding the iPad VR even and
consoles it's pretty cool and play made
skins textures come to the game and of
course 4k the super duper graphics plus
did not make that up from what it look
like a new lighting system that's
basically wood and then came the game
that probably got the biggest reaction
in the game SWAT war room yes people
might hear yeah well for people weren't
really mad so yeah feel Spencer said
he'd been to Japan to play it and so if
I'd we but feel Spencer yeah his new
official title that affects everyone
that tweet post been certified we'd I
mean what has me really feeling positive
about this we see a lot of good looking
Dragon Ball Z games
yeah but Arc System Works has a really
great reputation of making actually
funny games that play great mm-hmm
and look good and this seemed to really
capture the momentum of the
fights you see ya show and they
destructibility like it looks it looks
very much like yogi cares a Revelator
sign whatever that thing is called but
like it's so good to finally have a
mechanically deep Dragonball Z game and
this is these are characters and you
know the show has been going for years
I've grown up a bit but I've never been
truly satisfied with a Dragonball Z game
not even I mean the Buddha Buddha Chi
games were ok but this is like an
honest-to-god good fighting game from a
good you know developer and so I'm super
excited about it he just got turned into
a cookie he did blue loves cookies to
play devil's advocate how do we know
it's so good
yeah we're assuming a lot here and it
would always get gets dark my name's
hung up is like the charge time yeah
their power blasts and even their sort
of midair acrobatics yeah yeah that's
gonna be tricky for them to handle
though guilty gear does have yeah guilty
gear has a lot of good air and ground
movement movement options but it'll be
interesting to see how the kind of key
stuff works because that's usually what
breaks the pacing of most the Dragon
Ball Z biomes but I feel like they if
anyone can come over a good idea to kind
of overcome that it's Arc System Works I
mean they've got enough experience of
enemy fighters you know but the guilty
gear and they've got and the persona
stuff as well so I think they can figure
it out and I'm confident in in them
figuring out any way they did arena as
well yeah we was gonna look at black
does it online but then we had probably
like the coolest looking game of the
show in my opinion which was last night
which was like cool 3d 2.5 d but with
pixel and it just looks like retro
futuristic and it looks right hey do you
like Blade Runner yeah exactly with the
soundtrack as well yeah what is it I
don't know it looks like I don't know
and also should I know that name yeah I
was thinking that's Duke Lee but yeah it
does look unreal it was kind of weird
then you see these trees and that was
the first glimpse oh it's pixelated but
then like you said it's like 2.5 da
almost but the city itself was fully
animated but then right here this person
is pixelated it's I like it yeah kind of
looks like a
think of mine could be like a
Metroidvania type thing I try that cool
I feel like it's really narrative driven
like based on the hands are showing us
here yeah it showed him like thinking of
vignettes one oh boy
so this game was actually made in a game
jam back in 2014
been picked up by Microsoft and yeah it
looks that's real cool yeah all right
then we had artful escape which I
thought looked like a kind of Double
Fine it was that guy with the guitar and
the night in the woods vibrate and yeah
it was a big eyes yeah yeah but then he
started like platform it looked like a
rhythm platformer for a second but I
don't know if that's what they're going
for
yeah very quirky yeah really leaning
into that quirky nature so I'm gonna
move us on cuz we have like 30 code vein
vein anime Dark Soul anime dog films yep
that was the was that the trailer
they've already shown before though it's
like dogs house meets Tokyo ghoul which
is not an anime looks cool Namco Bandai
currently has quite a big hole where
doctors used to be so definitely trying
to fill that bad boy until blood-borne
two gets announced yeah because this was
announced with what they're prepared to
dine to remember they were like hey guys
do you like Dark Souls yeah we're not
gonna give you that but we'll give you
something that's vaguely like it yeah
they're really leaning into that and you
know then getting into the big first
party stuff so see if thieves I still
don't know what that game is shared
universe make I think it's like a it's
just a quirky pirates in yeah I like the
way that it kind of first of all how
everyone was eating been honest yeah I'm
to get rid of scurvy but I like the way
that kind of seamlessly went from its
PvE into PvP and also just traveled by
cannon yeah it seems like one of those
cases where maybe like battlegrounds
weird comparison but it with like three
good friends that you can have fun with
yeah yeah it might be it might hinge too
much upon that but if you could get in
the right situation at the right time
there might be fun I think this demo
went on for a little too long yeah I
like the tone generation for the first
two minutes yeah then it just kept going
yeah it was it was fun but then it just
went on for a little too long but it
seems like a fun game and I'm definitely
interested in I'm more interested in it
now than I was you know I think I think
they did hit the rare humor yeah I don't
know they gave a little more sense of
how maybe this discreet mission or
treasure hunt might work but again I
still no know how like the day-to-day
stuff is gonna unfold but it's good we
did see a the briefest of glimpses of
Tacoma with a release date so August 2nd
if any wants to give me that for my
birthday which is the next day no thanks
but nothing nothing really more from
Tacoma is just a very very short trailer
but I guess they sold out so games by
itself will have a lot more in Tacoma in
the coming week oh really
interesting [ __ ] Wow
and then we had what everyone thought
was a conquer conquer again I've got no
right lucky yeah I mean cool you played
lucky style right you were in VR yeah
yeah yeah so the game that they were
showing I mean similar in concept but
new levels that didn't look know that
looked very familiar to me so I you know
look they identified a cute character
they actually have it
that looks nice and mechanics that work
well it's gonna be a basic 3d adventure
I was gonna say I felt like I played
this on the ps1 yeah you know but that's
really bad some people want it back when
you I know when you're yeah you're
playing in VR did it ever occur to you
while you're playing that this would
just be better in later yeah a normal
screen yeah yeah yeah because you could
definitely tell like they had there were
certain types of puzzles they were going
for in VR which had to do with
perspective yeah platforming was a small
smaller part of it
mmm and it just seems like a strong
character platformer and it would be
better off living in that world rather
than in the world of the VR launch game
I'm not I'm not quite sure like looking
at them the way it moves it seems like
it looks a bit sluggish some people by
the way
Lucky's moving that I'm not quite sold
on yet like my platform is to be a
little more Pacey I don't think it's for
people looking for a real challenge you
know I think it's for the younger crowd
and the kids yeah speaking of Keaton
colourful also cuphead release date yeah
29 it was give me that from everything
it's a few days after nothing that's
trade yeah guess what oh yeah yeah this
has been for how long now it's been
showing up at paksas and E threes and I
mean I guess understandably so kind of
that hand-drawn animation it wasn't it
just gonna be boss fights and then
deciding yeah now it's actually it's
hard like from every time I played it
it's really hard but I'm excited to
finally play that yeah I'm a big fan of
finger guns yeah we crackdown was a bit
of a we had revealed for me I thought
they were gonna really go ham on it but
they I mean they had the Terry Crews
reveal yeah she's very Cruz he took of
not dune first I was gonna say yeah yeah
not him first but he an agent of mayhem
[Music]
pollution just watching this mean like
that's neither forward - in the air
which is nice but interesting they
didn't show any destructibility oh yeah
because they didn't really seem to have
a great game around that concept it was
almost just like look how impressive the
cloud is in yeah so do you think they're
actually backing away from there just
didn't feel like presenting it while
they're pimping the Scorpio I wonder
that the backing I feel like giving it
was all they could talk about for the
longest time yeah it seems like today
would have still been a great ride you
need to shout about it and I feel like
maybe they are backing away from it but
I guess we'll find out in the coming
months cuz coming out on November 7th
yeah the only the one small hint toward
it was when Terry Crews said like you
know if the drop bombs anymore you can
drop buildings yeah I could also be like
we're not sure what mode they're showing
off here cuz it's just like cutting
between different time yeah if this is
the multiplayer mode maybe it's like
we're not gonna have that in multiplayer
oh it could be just like oh we're not
gonna have it in single-player you know
it could be just specific to the mode
there yeah yeah they're showing off here
yeah but it would be really interesting
if they decide to come back away from it
yeah we also had a kind of like super
cut of all the idea Xbox games kind of
interesting ones like surviving Mars
path of Exile fable path of Exile I've
been playing that a little bit on PC
over the past couple of years on hello
neighbor
Conan exiles but they didn't really got
much screen time no just kind of hey
these games probably cuz if you play
enough Conan then you know you're
eventually gonna see genitalia
then we had like another one that we
kept calling like a Dark Souls in which
was ashen ashen ashen one very stylized
it looked very nice was that the one
wearing the guy's face was completely
blank and he just had this mustache yeah
yeah I had that kind of feel Spencer was
like the visuals of this or the style of
it sells it in its entirety and when I
saw it I was like I know about that feel
but it looks kind of cool like
everything that's kind of smooth and
yes looking near colorful had some
interesting character design with the
spider enemy and very doctor there's a
bit where the camera was panning down
and it was just a light in the corner
and I was like that looks kind of like a
bonfire and then it just kind of went
over and it was a fire but not it looks
very dark souls ii everything is dark
those these days so even a Sasson screed
everything's kidding then we have the
life is strange prequel life strange
before the storm looks like Chloe and
Rachel amber their friendship before the
events of life strange hmm yeah yeah I
mean people said I know people
complaining like when they talked about
more life is strange don't bring the
characters back technically they bring
them back kind of this got one of the
louder applauses at the conference like
for the crowd yeah that's obviously not
the best barometer but I try play life
is strange because I still have it I
hear it like you like it really like it
it doesn't seem like my type of game it
starts off with some awkward rain and
then it kind of smoothes out and it
comes a bit better and it's just like if
you enjoy the themes and the way it hits
some of the themes we're not gonna spend
the whole time to my live strange but
some of the stuff that it tackles is but
yeah so this is quite interesting
because this is all the stuff that you
hear about in the first game and you
actually get to experience it like here
Chloe's dad dying which is a big big
part of that game yeah hope they bring
back that creepy janitor who looks off
the squirrel he's my hero
bring him back he should be the big bat
he should be inside that twist or
whatever he's those bearing down just
him spinning in there what I thought was
quite interesting was the fact that at
the beginning when they had that like
sort of pre-roll where they had all the
big games there was a lot of shadow of
war in there yeah instead of like their
own games but yeah the shadow war had
another good show a great nemesis memnos
that was M&E system had
the best about yeah he was incredible I
was talking to Pete while I was going on
his name was bruised yeah but but Michel
de platter when the creative director on
stage said Bruce it's not but then that
jog my memory he sounded weirdly like
Bruce the shark from Finding Nemo I know
and I know that might be a stretch but
it was too similar it was uncanny and
I'm wondering if that was intentional
like it was so good I was like just get
rid of talion make him them in ways like
popping you with his cheese Bruce this
is the thing I'm worried about this game
is when when you meet like a nemesis or
something and they're you know they were
talking about that other guy wasn't him
like the machine man or it was like a
cyborg cyborg walk at the end he grabbed
tallien and then literally proceeded to
give him his life story
it went on for like oh yeah for a minute
add cold flakes and then I came outside
to find you but then I stopped this shot
to get some milk and I was like alright
man get on with it like it really sucked
the tension out of that moment I hope it
doesn't do that I find annoying like I'm
replaying the first game in a minute and
it just having like being in the middle
of battle and there goes Ranger yeah let
me tell you my life story but what I
actually tweeted by this one was going
on the thing that I really liked that
they showed a lot of obviously in this
showing was that the humor is still
there because everything so far has been
so go fast whereas you kind of forget
that shadow of mortal was a really funny
game like rap back yeah what a guy so
I'm kind I'm really really glad that
they keep it up yeah should be fun I
like it interesting this was the time
that I had to go to the loo this was a
long and then we had an Ori - yeah yeah
I was very worried when they brought the
piano yes I thought oh god we're gonna
get a song yeah they just kind of like
zoomed into the screen and damn this
looks good
such a beautiful looking game I'm
excited for Maury it's one of my
favorite venues as they call them yeah
Froggy's massive if you looked it you'd
get well hi sure I really loved how
gorgeous the game was Jeff suppose
against how difficult the first one was
and it you know like I'm assuming
they're gonna make this one just as
difficult in those time sections when
you're escaping yeah I wonder if they'll
bring things like that back but yeah
Orion blind forest was one of my
favorite games fifteen or fourteen yeah
it had some really interesting like the
movement we kept the kind of like
jumping teleporting yourself from yeah
pointing that was my favorite it was
really exhilarating which is what I
didn't expect from it it's such a calm
game for most of it and then you have
these moments of like tension and like
exhilaration in trying to get out of
areas I hope they kind of have more of
that stuff here as well as it and
there's now yeah I'll be back or e2 or
in the will of the West then we had like
the weirdly the biggest cheer for the
night from what it watching the stream
had seemed like the biggest cheer came
from OG xbox backwards comprising
honestly it was weird like they
mentioned backwards compatibility
earlier in the press conference and then
I thought he was hinting at that but
then they backed off I got never mind
but yeah Pete you were wondering if like
the discs will work yeah cuz I still
have some original Xbox games yeah I
would love to just put those right in
there and function I don't I can't think
of a reason why technically it shouldn't
work yeah I mean if they're working on
the emulation software right well so the
the the one reason I think they might
limit it though is the fact that the
Xbox 360 backwards compatibility was a
bit rocky yeah where a lot of times you
get a game that would work more often
than not but when it didn't work you
liked it some games you couldn't
actually finish right other games were
just like things would look corrupted or
sound awful so they might not want to
just let that be the case
so they might just release games like
one by one sort of like or enable them
one by one you know as they're you know
quote-unquote ready yeah but what would
be awesome if it was just wide open and
it all worked and I could just put in my
disks and download games that would be
awesome
yeah yeah they've got to figure out a
better way to cuz I remember I really
went through a phase of wanting to play
Mass Effect again and I didn't have my
disc and in order to download it I had
to do it on the Xbox Store
on my PC for it to appear in my library
they need to have that system more
streamlined I think yeah I think
everyone talks about wanting backwards
compatibility but it's one of those
things where it seems like once they
have it it's like okay cool and then
they move on to being like we want this
now but I still have a few Xbox original
Xbox games that I'd maybe play crimson
skies I thought they were I thought he
was gonna bring up night so Republic and
then use as a segue to anthem yeah but
no but they more 4k updates yeah so for
tech years Final Fantasy 15 Resident
Evil 7 Ghost Recon wildlands and rocket
League the game that continues to give
man but and then finally the final game
anthem anthem what you think they're all
your hands up yeah stop it it's an all
day I heard you do watching the dumb
breathe Charlotte really really good
yeah it had a great show the Iron Man
game I've always wanted yeah exactly
that's exactly it
just the mobility of 42 biosuit and I
mean like when we're walking through
that market at one point and it's looked
incredible yeah I had like I'm amazed of
the kind of I guess the cultural
touchstones that it seemed like it was
putting in together so like we said
Ironman when you were walking through
that market it kind of felt Star Wars II
yeah same time and it felt like Jurassic
Park you know we're kind of waiting like
horizon ambience yeah yeah like lush
world and animals that look strange
the idea of the suits having like just
in classes and that being like a
mechanical thing or just even yeah 20
starts array of various yeah yeah this
is straight up iron man right now yeah
and there's bits later with the missiles
where it's straight up a scene from the
first time the mortars yeah more and
then the loads of smaller missiles that
target loads of enemies the navigation
is seems really appealing just that by
kind of sky like falling through the sky
jetpack but yeah like it obviously the
destiny kind of vibe of different
classes like this is a ranger I think
then the other guy was using a Colossus
I'm not mistaken but yeah I like the
idea of I'm sure there's at least one
more class maybe two that you can
actually bring on co-op missions with
this was really cool going underwater
constrained yeah yeah this world looks
massive
hey yeah it does and I'm like how many
of them are there how many of them can
maybe they showed a lot more than I
thought they would honest yeah wasn't a
surprise with this demo yeah I think you
look at well yeah is this supposed to be
like a interstellar or something like
that I know any like flu is like he
feels like looks like a wormhole or
something right so yeah you might used
to be like you know a few planets
limited to that system yeah it does I
mean like I want to see more of the
story because that's that's the thing
that I love about Bioware games right
they create these rich really broad
worlds for you to lose yourself in and I
want more of that and like characters
and stuff like that I'm hoping they have
still have those things because I know
it's possible to do that a games like
destiny show that you can build some
characters that are engaging and
memorable but I mean generally there's
not that many of them not on the same
level or something like Mass Effect or
you know any other even cult or or
something like that I'm hoping that they
have loads of like really
I need like a modern for example a
character to really fall in love again
you know Rex and I saw a lot of people
saying that this reveal was very
reminiscent of the divisions first
gameplay reveal mmm-hmm
like the way that they had people
dropping in I loved I loved the woman
who sound like Daria but yeah really
excited but yeah I agree with you and
that I really hope that it manages to
balance not only being a fun like co-op
multiplayer game but also having that
human human element to kind of keep me
invested in it because I think that's
the reason I sort of dropped out from
destiny until the taken king where they
added more characterization today just
because there wasn't that investment I
guess yeah it's just you know you're in
space shooting aliens for a little while
and was like
I don't care about this anymore yeah
money - yeah reasons these stuff I'm the
more ISOs like see of this and the more
I'm watching it again the more I'm
really excited because thing I love
destiny for its mechanics and for its
actual gameplay and how it felt
cooperatively and just because you know
Bungie such a fine tuned studio in terms
of making a good shooter but all the
story of course is in the grimoire if
you want to go online
knowing that Bioware is doing something
like this and how much emphasis they've
historically since their inception
placed on a narrative mmm has me excited
like a third person destiny with a good
story that's surrounding everything
sexualizing it is pretty appealing at
this point obviously we've only seen
tennis minutes the less but I'm excited
I like that they did the loop box
opening animation directly on one more
thing this character right there the
jump looks like a different class and
everybody else has a cloak on them
assuming that's not just an aesthetic
thing for their character so and showing
for people you know implies maybe
there's four classes I would assume you
know but yeah I love necks and excellent
suits in yeah Bioware so I like that
you've got like a rocket-powered run as
well as a boost and that's coming out
next yeah but guys overall what are your
thoughts on scorpion um I'm interested
in it I'm gonna buy it I think the price
for me is as someone who you know
obsessively buys this stuff where
regardless I mean a game plan I have
nine GameCubes me
this is okay you're serious sweet it
does not come out in the UK I got one
hallowed them out my love you're like
yeah so like I'll buy it but I feel like
I don't know if they sold it to the
wider you know gaming audience as well
as they would need to to kind of have
uptick on it really quickly yeah I think
the lack of first party games is a real
hindrance
I know they don't want to split their
bases and all that kind of stuff but
they needed one big game to come out and
be like boom look at this they had Forza
I don't think for and I don't think the
broader gaming
audience can get what they want out of a
racing game simulation games racing
simulation games have look good they
always look good you need something
fresh new and exciting and like Fairplay
to Microsoft they had a lot of good
games they had Metro and you know and a
lot of good looking games but I feel
like they needed I kind of like to put
their flag down halo gear something like
that or something brand new Microsoft
Studios and at the moment they're saying
we've got a bunch of games that will
also be available other places they keep
saying exclusive but being very vague
about that term what is exclusive mean
is at and exclusive is it outright
console exclusive do you have one piece
of DLC they didn't specify that and I
think that right now if I was kind of
not an obsessive console buyer I'd be
like okay it looks cool but five hundred
dollars five hundred pounds right now
when I've got a perfectly fine ps4 ps4
pro or Xbox one and you keep telling me
that everything works on everything like
you've shown me no advantage you've
provided an option an expensive option I
don't know man I think it's gonna be a
great piece of hardware but I don't know
if it's an essential piece of hardware
yeah I think especially if you have a PC
as well there's someone who's a lot of
this stuff because a lot of the things
you know we're Court has exclusive we're
also pitched as Windows 10 games yeah so
if you you've already got a PSP no
PlayStation 4 and Sherin even an Xbox
you're gonna set yeah but but it's a
beautiful console yeah I'm not really
one for like how the console looks but I
was like that looks nice I can see that
my living room it's got that hot
Dragonball Z game as well like what'd
you think I still really unclear on
which games were like Tamar said actual
exclusives which were time exclusives
which I can just play on my existing
Xbox one or ps4 Perot or something I
think the price is fair and I think I'm
I do want to get one now that I've seen
it outside of the X I actually thought
Microsoft had a really good conference
in general I like that they seem to go
just game game game game game they
brought in a few people to talk about
the games I wish those casters didn't
come on maybe that would be more excited
about the Darwin project yeah someone
from mixer chimed in yeah I would didn't
like a focus on mixer but all-in-all I
was actually pleasantly surprised what
for
two games I showed and it sounded like
exhausting at the beginning but once I
just kept seeing them but yeah I'm I'm
coming away from it just being more
excited for anthem and for Metro Exodus
especially but going back to a question
about the Scorpio or sorry the xbox one
act it's difficult to go back I was just
thinking yeah I am I'm excited for it I
would like you said I would love to see
more exclusives announced like first
party but I think this is definitely
good start
alright well that was it for the Xbox
one X
don't say Scorpio difficult to say Xbox
one X reveal make sure you join us here
again at half-past eight specific time
for the Bethesda pre-show conference
chat I guess the pre-show for their
press conference that starts at 9:00 and
of course keep your eyes peeled to games
water comm you to become select games
for twitch TV drama such games for
twisty Bioko twitch and then someone
from mixer chimed in
[Music]